elon is probably one of the most
influential men in the world but his
family history remains an enigma for
many of my viewers so i thought i'd take
the time to introduce you to his father
errol musk and why elon claims he is one
of the most evil people he has ever met
so stick around this video will give you
quite an insight into the life of our
favorite billionaire family history we
have seen countless pictures of elon and
his siblings with their mum mae musk but
we never see any with their father this
is because the relationship of the musk
siblings with their father errol is
complicated to say the least errol was
born in pretoria south africa in 1946 to
an army sergeant father and a british
mother he would grow up to become a very
successful electro-mechanical engineer a
trait he undoubtedly passed along to his
son elon errol grew up in the same
neighborhood as may and the pair dated
on and off in university may would go on
to become a supermodel and a dietitian
she later told elon's biographer ashley
vance that errol relentlessly pursued
her hand in marriage and he would never
stop proposing to her the couple finally
married in 1970. this is another trait
that errol passed along to his son elon
also pursued his first wife justine
similarly while at university in canada
justine recounted how elon would call
her insistently and would not take no
for an answer she even said to elon's
biographer you can't blow him off i do
think of him as the terminator he locks
his gaze onto something and says it
shall be mine bit by bit he won me over
nine months after errol and may tied the
knot elon came into the world in 1971.
the family's early years were happy
enough they had kimball the following
year and elon's sister tosca came along
in 1974. eril and may realized very
early on that elon was different as
errol told south african radio station
702's money show with bruce whitfield
elon has always been a very deep thinker
when he was very small around three or
four years old he would ask questions
like where is the whole world this set
him apart from other kids his age in
those days the musk family had a
comfortable life in pretoria along with
his engineering business errol had also
become a successful real estate
developer according to elon errol was a
very talented engineer with an extremely
high iq although he never accepted it
errol greatly influenced elon's bent
towards engineering and he benefited
immensely from his father's skills errol
has mentioned on many occasions that he
took young elon to his engineering work
sites where he got hands-on experience
laying bricks plumbing and electrical
wiring he was also the one who
introduced elon to the world of
computers and programming when elon was
11 years old he insisted errol take him
to a computer programming lecture at the
university of the witwatersrand
johannesburg although he was too young
for the lecture errol used his
engineering connections to get him in
errol later recounted the story in the
same interview with bruce whitfield he
had dropped off elon for the lecture and
when he came back after three hours to
get him he waited and waited but elon
wouldn't come out of the lecture hall he
finally stepped inside to see what was
going on and witnessed that everyone had
left but elon with his sleeves rolled up
was deep in conversation with the
lecturers they were so impressed with
his enthusiasm and knowledge that they
forced errol to buy him his first laptop
and that's how elon's love affair with
computer programming began this love for
programming would make him his first
million when he and his brother kimball
sold their first company zip 2 to
compact in 1999. incidentally the
brothers borrowed the funds required to
start this company from errol so far you
must be thinking that it sounds like
elon had an extremely happy childhood
which he spent with a very supportive
father so why does he call him evil well
the cracks began to appear when errol
and may divorced in 1979 when elon was
only 8 years old cracks in the musk
family although from the outside it may
have appeared that elon had a happy
childhood in his words it was full of
misery thanks mainly to errol and his
behavior towards may after their divorce
when they divorced the couple had only
been married for nine years mae later
described it as leaving an emotionally
and physically abusive relationship
after the divorce mei and the children
had to change their lifestyles
drastically the comfortable lavish
existence under their father's wealth
was suddenly gone and mae struggled for
a long time as a single mother to make
ends meet the divorce was not amicable
and may had to work several jobs to
support her three children she told an
interviewer that she had to buy them
second-hand clothes and find the
cheapest ingredients in the store to
cook the meals because she had no money
she also recollected that this one time
she cried when one of the children
spilled milk on the floor as she had no
more money to buy them more this
undoubtedly caused elon a lot of trauma
and resentment against his father
despite that in 1981 he decided to move
in with his father to a suburb of
johannesburg it would be a decision that
he would later come to regret the next
eight years spent with errol would shape
not only his world views but also his
views of him as an evil man elon later
revealed to rolling stone in an
interview in 2017 that his father was a
terrible human being he said my dad will
have a carefully thought out plan of
evil he will plan evil although he never
gave any specifics as to why he
considered errol to be evil he went on
to say that people have no idea how bad
errol was and how he has committed
almost every crime possible after
listening to this interview it's hard
not to imagine that his father must have
done something terrible in those days
that led elon to formulate such a strong
opinion of him and since elon claims it
was not physical violence it must have
been something external that left a deep
emotional scar in young elon's mind
errol's questionable past although elon
stopped himself from giving further
details in that interview this is what i
know from my own research errol has
confessed to shooting and killing three
people who broke into his home he was
later cleared of any wrongdoings but it
takes a different kind of man to pull
off something like that even if it is in
self-defense the man also has a child
with his step-daughter from a different
marriage jaina bizadenhout jaina's mum
married aryl when she was only four
years old and she grew up with him as
the major father figure in her life her
mum later divorced him but she
maintained contact with him their paths
crossed in 2017 which led to the birth
of a son in 2018. errol claimed that
jaina turned to him for comfort after a
breakup with her boyfriend and the child
was conceived in the heat of the moment
this incident was a huge embarrassment
for the musk family and further
indicated the man's moral state errell
has also claimed in multiple business
insider articles that he owned part of
an emerald mine in zambia which made him
so rich that he couldn't even close his
safe with all the money he was making
however elon refuted this claim in a
tweet saying that errol didn't own an
emerald mine and that he had to work his
way through college ending up with over
a hundred thousand dollars in student
debt whatever may be the truth one thing
is for sure there is no love lost
between elon and his father errol for
his part has not been silent on the
matter either in a 2018 interview with
the daily mail he said elon needs to
grow up and that he's having a tantrum
like a spoiled child anyways after
living with his father for eight years
elon left for canada in 1989. a few
months later may also moved to canada
with tosca so elon kimball mae and tosca
all lived for a while in toronto elon
then transferred to the university of
pennsylvania where he graduated in 1997
with a bachelor of arts degree in
physics and a bachelor of science degree
in economics from the wharton school
according to elon his father did not
approve of him moving to canada in fact
errol didn't think that his son would
make much of himself and that he would
be back in south africa within three
months not only did he not ever go back
to south africa but he also went on to
make himself the richest person in the
world founding two of the most
successful and innovative companies in
the world spacex and tesla i think
elon's drive to save humanity and his
aggressive push against the established
system of the world stems from his
childhood pain the key to his worldview
can be found somewhere in this deep
trauma bond that he shares with his
father what do you think am i right and
assuming that elon's goal to save
humanity is rooted in the complicated
relationship he shares with his father
let me know down in the comment section
below if you enjoyed this video
subscribe to the channel and don't
forget to hit the like button see you in
the next one